it's not just because they huddle
together by the thousand that makes
penguins so hard to count it's because
they do so in the most remote places on
the planet
great swathe of Antarctica are two
isolated even for a plane to reach but
now scientists are counting penguins
from space satellite photos are so good
individual birds can be spotted against
the ice and they found there are twice
as many penguins as they had once
thought this used to be the second
largest emperor penguin colony in the
world but they're in trouble emperor
penguins need sea ice to breed on and
it's melting as the world warms the
places where emperor penguins can breed
and successfully live will become
smaller and smaller until maybe there
won't be any left
there will still be some emperor
penguins by the end of this century in
80 years time but in most cases by then
their populations are plummeting
downwards so how much longer they will
survive after that depends very much on
what we as a species do and how we
change the climate over the coming
decades Antarctica has lost 3 trillion
tons of ice over the last 25 years
half of that has been in the last five
what happens to the rest is uncertain
and scientists are drilling deep into
the ice sheet in the search of clues
this sliver of ice comes from hundreds
of meters below the surface and it's
trapped air bubbles from tens of
thousands of years ago
it tells scientists something about the
atmosphere in the distant past but it
also helps them understand where the
planet might be heading in future when
we're looking at an ice core what we're
doing is we're analyzing it we're going
essentially back through time so we've
got the present and we're working
backwards through time and we can go
back in the order of just a few decades
with shallow cores and potentially we
can go back nearly a million years with
the really deep records
[Music]
three million years ago greenhouse gas
levels in the atmosphere were much the
same as today but the planet was two
degrees warmer and sea levels 20 meters
higher it could once again be our
destiny
so Antarctica is our largest reservoir
as freshwater I mean in a very
unrealistic scenario he melted all of
the ants at the whole of Antarctica
you'd be increasing sea levels by around
60 meters obviously that's not likely to
happen any time in the near future but
it does have the potential to rise sea
levels in the order of several meters in
the sort of future warming scenario Sky
News will join scientists from British
Antarctic Survey on a six-week mission
to monitor the frozen continent
if greenhouse gas emissions continue to
rise the ripples from what's happening
10,000 miles away at the bottom of the
planet will in time affect us all Thomas
More Sky News
[Music]
you